SHAWN BUSOLITS: Welcome
to the Quickstart video
for the IMA HTML5 SDK.
The IMA SDK for HTML5 allows
you to display inline videos
and overlay ads on
web video content.
Its most common use is
to show preroll video ads
before a video is
played on a website,
but it can also be used to
show TV-style commercial ad
breaks in long-form content.
When we're done with
this video, you'll
have a simple web
page that plays
video ads onto content video.
If you want to follow along,
download the sample video
player we've hosted at the
link on the screen now.
Once you have that file
downloaded and unzipped,
you can host the sample
web page by navigating
to the unzipped folder in your
terminal or command prompt
and running python
-m SimpleHTTPServer.
That will host the sample web
page at local host port 8,000.
Let's see what the sample
video player looks like.
As you can see,
the page currently
just contains a Play button.
When we click that, we
see our content video.
Now let's take a look at the
files that make this happen.
The sample video player
contains three files--
index.html, which is the sample
HTML for our sample web page,
style.css, which is the style
sheet that lays out the sample
web page, and ads.js, which
is where all of our Javascript
will go.
Currently, this is set up to
just play the content video
when we click the Play button.
We're going to do all of our
work in the JavaScript file,
but let's first walk
through the HTML
so we know what
we're working with.
The two most important
things in this HTML file
are the video player and
the ad container div.
The video player will
play our content,
and the ad container will
be populated by the SDK
to show ads on top
of the video player.
In most web browsers, the SDK
will use its own video player
to play ads, not your player.
That SDK-owned player,
along with any ad
UI, will be created in this div.
We also create a Play button
at the bottom of the page
to start the video.
You'll also notice that
we're loading our CSS
file in the head of the HTML.
This sets up our component
sizes and locations
to ensure our ad
container is on top of
and completely covers
the video player.
The SDK will
automatically show the div
to play ads, and hide it
when content is playing.
Lastly, at the
bottom of the page,
we load the IMA SDK, followed by
the ads.js file in which we'll
be working.
Now that we have a basic idea
of the HTML for the page,
let's take a look
at the JavaScript.
Currently, it's getting
handles to the video player
and the Play button, and
playing the video when
a user clicks the button.
Let's modify this
to request and show
an ad before our content plays.
First, we're going to create
an ad display container.
This SDK object holds a
handle to the ad container
div we talked about
in the HTML file,
as well as your video player.
Remember earlier that I said
the SDK will use its own video
player in most browsers?
We give it a handle
to your video player
here for those instances where
it can't use its own video
player, like older versions
of iPhone and Android,
which only support one
video player at a time.
In those cases, the SDK will
reuse your video player.
Now that we have an
ad display container,
we can create an ads loader.
An ads loader is used by
the SDK to request a vast ad
response from an ad server.
This response contains
tracking URLs, as well as
links to the media for the ad.
We're going to listen for two
events on the ads loader--
ads manager loaded and ad error.
Ads manager loaded will be fired
when the SDK has successfully
created an ads manager for us.
We'll talk about what an
ads manager is in a minute.
Ad error will be
fired if something
goes wrong in the process
of requesting ads.
Let's fill in that
ad error handler now.
When something goes
wrong requesting ads,
we've got no chance
of playing ads,
so we'll just log the error
and play our content video.
We'll fill in the ads manager
loaded handler in a bit.
Next, we'll add a
content ended handler
to let the SDK know
when to play postrolls.
We'll listen for the video
player's ended event,
and call content complete
on the ads loader
to let it know it can play
postrolls, if it has any.
Now that we've
created our ads loader
and assigned event listeners,
let's build our ads request.
The ads request object
contains all the information
the SDK needs to request
ads for your video player.
First, we provide
an ad tag URL, which
points to the vast response
that the SDK needs in order
to know which ad to play
and where to get it from.
Then we provide linear and
non-linear ad slot widths
and heights.
These tell the SDK what
size ads you want to show.
The linear width
and height should
be the same as
your video player,
and the non-linear
width and height
can be anything that will
fit inside your ad container.
The most common type
of non-linear ad
is a bottom-third ad, which
fills the bottom third
of the video player.
So we'll set the width to
the full width of our player,
and the height to one-third
the full height of our player.
Now that we've built
our ads request,
we can give it to the ads
loader to request ads.
We're going to modify
the onPlay button click
function to do this when the
user clicks the Play button.
We'll also initialize the
ad display container here.
This must be done as the
result of a user action,
and clicking on the Play
button will be that user
action for this sample.
If the ads loader successfully
loads ads using your ads
request, it will fire
the ads manager loaded
event I mentioned earlier.
This event will give
you a handle to an ads
manager, which is your main
interface with the SDK.
It provides ad interactions
like pause, resume, and volume
control.
Let's write the handler
for that event now.
The first thing we'll do is
store a local handle to the ads
manager provided in the
ads manager loaded event.
I'm going to declare
the ads manager
variable on the global scope,
so that we'll have access to it
in the functions we write later.
We retrieve the ads manager from
the ads manager loaded event
and provide a handle to
our video player, which
allows the SDK to track
our content position if we
want to play midrolls.
Now we add a handler
for an ad error.
This will be fired if
something goes wrong in the SDK
during ad playback--
for example,
if the SDK gets a badly
encoded media file
and needs to abort playback.
The ad error handler will be
the same as the ads loader
error handler, but we'll
modify it to also destroy
the ads manager if it exists.
Now we need to add content
pause and resume handlers.
Because the SDK plays
ads in a separate player,
it needs to tell us to pause
our content when ads start.
Otherwise, we'd have
our content playing
at the same time as the ads.
That's what this event is for.
The content pause handler
will pause your content
so an ad can play.
We also need to remove our
content ended handler here.
If we're in a browser that
causes the SDK to reuse
our content player, leaving
that listener enabled
during ad playback
will cause us to call
content complete on the ads
loader when the ad finishes.
And we only want
that to be called
when our content finishes.
Similarly, we'll
declare our contact
resume handler,
which will be called
when an ad break finishes.
This readds our content ended
handler, and plays our content.
Once we've got our ads
manager handler set up,
we can initialize and
start playing ads.
The init method takes the
size of your video player
and the view mode.
The view mode is the mode
you consider your player
to be in when you start
ads, either full-screen,
if the video is
full-screen, or normal,
if it's embedded in a page.
Since this player is
embedded in the page,
we'll pass in Normal
for the view mode.
If you're using ad rolls
to play an ad playlist,
your preroll will start playing
ads immediately on init.
For single ads,
preroll playback won't
start until we call Start.
Now let's take a look
at what we've got.
Now when I load the page
and click the Play button,
we see a preroll ad.
Once the preroll finishes,
we see our content video.
If we keep watching, we'll
see some midrolls breaking up
our content.
And that's all there is to it.
If you're looking to
expand on this sample,
check out our advanced
sample on GitHub
and the rest of
our documentation
on developers.google.com.
We've also got some
more sample tags
so you can play around
with different ad formats.
These will all
work in your player
without any additional
modifications.
If you have any questions,
feel free to visit us
on the support forum,
and we'll see you around.
[MUSIC PLAYING]